amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen jump der
streit um einen pitch bend gegen den
us-präsidenten geht in eine
entscheidende phase und spaltet die usa
mega fusion in einem krisen markt
opel-mutter peugeot und fiat chrysler
wollen gemeinsam neue märkte erschließen
auch bei der e-mobilität ehrung eines
inhaftierten der von china festgehaltene
uigurische professor ilham tohti erhält
den sacharow preis des europaparlaments
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend kristin otto
und ich heißen sie willkommen zu unserem
nachrichtenüberblick am 18 dezember ja
schön benannt und wir beginnen mit dem
blick in die usa
dort stimmt das repräsentantenhaus heute
darüber ab ob es ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump geben wird er wäre der erst dritte
präsident in der geschichte amerikas der
sich einem solchen boot umstellen muss
für die demokraten ein historischer tag
trump selbst spricht von einem kreuzzug
der opposition
der ball liegt jetzt erstmal bei den
abgeordneten im repräsentantenhaus hier
haben die oppositionellen demokraten die
mehrheit
es gilt als sicher dass sie für ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren stimmen das
verfahren selbst wird dann in der
anderen kammer dem senat geführt dort
haben die republikaner von präsident
trump die mehrheit
britta jäger berichtet vor dem kapitol
stehen sie in der kälte aber das ist es
den demonstranten wert wenn es nach
ihnen geht muss trump aus dem weißen
haus entfernt werden und zwar schnell
weil unsere demokratie auf dem spiel
steht die welt guckt zu deutschland
guckt zu mir ist das so peinlich dass
unser land von einem betrüger und lügner
repräsentiert wird dafür zu sorgen dass
diese gangster nicht unser land
übernehmen
sechs stunden lang will das
repräsentantenhaus debattieren dann im
anschluss über eine amtsenthebung
abstimmen
diese regeln hatten sich die
abgeordneten am morgen auferlegt die
argumente altbekannt der präsident hat
die macht seines amtes benutzt um
missbräuchlich einen persönlichen
politischen vorteile herauszuschlagen
auf kosten der nationalen sicherheit
wir haben hier einen präsidenten der
nichts von dem getan hat was man ihm
vorwirft sie werfen ihm machtmissbrauch
vor mit schwammiger grundlage
machtmissbrauch wird nur immer und immer
wieder erwähnt macht das verfahren
spürbar zu schaffen mit einem bizarren
wut brief wendet er sich gestern an die
oberste frau der demokraten
die plo sie spricht darin von einem
unzulässigen impeachment mit denen die
demokraten ihre am zeh verletzten und
der demokratie den offenen krieg
erklären würden es besteht kaum ein
zweifel dass das repräsentantenhaus mit
einer demokratischen mehrheit für eine
anklage des präsidenten stimmt der
wunsch der demonstranten aber kam
tatsächlich aus dem weißen haus zu jagen
wird sich wohl nicht erfüllen
ja also auch wenn das
amtsenthebungsverfahren am ende
wahrscheinlich scheitert elmar theveßen
in washington warum ist es trotzdem von
so großer bedeutung für das land
ja es geht hier um den kern der
amerikanischen demokratie nämlich die
frage ob der us-präsident sein amt
missbraucht hat damit eine fremde macht
mit informationen einfluss nimmt auf den
amerikanischen wahlkampf und damit auf
die amerikanische demokratie das ist ein
viel schwerwiegender vorwurf als bei den
früheren amtsenthebungsverfahren 1868
und 1998
und es gibt noch einen wesentlichen
unterschied ich war 1998 schon hier beim
verfahren gegen bill clinton
damals konnten die abgeordneten sehr
offen sprechen auch die seiner eigenen
partei konnten ihn kritisieren und
konnten auch gegen ihn stimmen in diesem
verfahren
heute ist es so dass der us präsident in
seinem brief den wir ja erwähnt haben
ganz klar sagt jeder der im kongress für
eine amtsenthebung stimmt und ich
zitiere da der verachtet die wähler und
hast dir das amerikanische
verfassungssystem und das sorgt dafür
dass diese abgeordneten allen voran auch
die republikaner keine gewissensfreiheit
haben einer dieser republikaner hat das
verfahren vorhin sogar hier hinter mir
als umsturzversuch bezeichnet und das
bedeutet dass im wahlkampf
jeder der gegen trump gestimmt hat als
volksverräter als verfassungsfeind
gekennzeichnet werden kann das wird sehr
hässlich werden im nächsten jahr und ich
glaube das könnte amerika doch
gravierend auch verändern
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung elmar
wie sehen die nächsten schritte im
amtsenthebungsverfahren aus welche
hürden müssen konkret genommen werden
antworten finden sie unter anderem in
einem ausführlichen erklärt video auf
heute.de
und in der zdf- heute- app
elektromobilität und autonomes fahren
herausforderungen denn viele
autohersteller alleine nicht gewachsen
sind
das führt zu neuen allianzen wie der von
peugeot und fiat chrysler dass sie
fusionieren wollen war bekannt jetzt
wurde der vertrag unterschrieben
mit peugeot und fiat chrysler gehen zwei
ähnlich große hersteller zusammen
gemeinsam wollen sie etwa 8,7 millionen
fahrzeuge im jahr bauen weltweit wird
der neue konzern die nummer vier hinter
volkswagen toyota und renault nissan wo
juden leinhos berichtet es ist die ehe
von zwei höchst ungleichen partnern
geländewagen der marken ram und jeep die
verkaufsschlager von fiat chrysler
dagegen geht es bei der petro gruppe hin
zu elektro autos wie den opel corsa
gleichwohl es könnte funktionieren um
die größe größe größe größe das ist
einfach das entscheidende massen
autogeschäft und ich glaube fiat geht es
auch darum technologischen anschluss zu
finden denn das ist der hersteller würde
ich sagen unter den größeren die am
stärksten zurück gefallen waren
beide wollen neue kunden erobern fiat
chrysler mit der marke jeep hofft auf
mehr erfolg in europa und in asien
die pilgergruppe mit zitronen und opel
will in nordamerika stärker werden
optimismus bei opel in rüsselsheim
firmenchef loschelder sieht gute chancen
durch die mega fusion und die
gewerkschaft auch
zunächst mal macht es sinn bei den
herausforderungen die die
automobilindustrie hat die
entwicklungskosten für autonomes fahren
bis digitalisierung andere
antriebstechniken auf mehr fahrzeuge zu
verteilen und damit ist opel teil eines
großen konzerns was durchaus ein vorteil
ist geschäft aber es gilt als harter
sanierer
opel machte er wieder profitabel in dem
er tausende jobs abbaute
diesmal sehen experten eher
arbeitsplätze in italien in gefahr
ich glaube vier werke in europa das ist
der problemfall
das ist das was bis jetzt sollte mal
unter dem strich fallen wird und die
sich jetzt da gewaltig verbessern müssen
die partner dieser auto hochzeit
versprechen kein einziges der 28 werke
in europa zu schließen da ist skepsis
angebracht denn erklärtes ziel ist auch
milliarden euro kosten zu sparen
morgen ist es drei jahre her dass der
terrorist anis amri mit einem lkw in den
weihnachtsmarkt in der berliner
gedächtniskirche raste zwölf menschen
starben mehr als 100 wurden verletzt
viele leiden noch immer unter den folgen
der amri untersuchungsausschuss des
bundestages hat schon 72 mal getagt
heute zogen fdp linke und grüne
zwischenbilanz und sehen noch viel
aufklärungsbedarf vor allem auch bei der
frage wie gut deutsche behörden
zusammengearbeitet haben nicole diekmann
sie gehören mittlerweile zum
weihnachtsmarkt wie glühwein und
gebrannte mandeln poller und
absperrungen um schlimmstes zu
verhindern
hier in berlin ermordete der islamist
anis amri zwölf menschen
seit märz 2018 befasst sich ein
untersuchungsausschuss mit dem fall
der bundesinnenminister oberster
dienstherr der sicherheitsbehörden
beteuert im zdf-interview maximalen
aufklärungswillen ich bin nicht zum
ersten mal mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss konfrontiert und
da ist immer die beste antwort totale
offenheit totale transparenz gegenüber
den abgeordneten die in solchen
verfahren fall
untersuchen fdp linke und grüne bewerten
das komplett anders ihre selten
einmütige vernichtende zwischenbilanz
die behörden würden zeugenaussagen
verhindern und akten nachträglich
schwärzen ja sogar frisieren ich möchte
ungern im plenum des deutschen
bundestages stehen zur abschlussdebatte
und sagen ich kann den fall nicht
vollumfänglich bewerten weil die
bundesregierung ist nicht alle achten
und alle zeugen gegeben hat die wir
benötigen herr seehofer hat es in der
hand das zu tun und er tut ist nicht ein
zentraler vorwurf das bundeskriminalamt
habe amri kolossal unterschätzt im
u-ausschuss sagte ein ermittler aus das
bka habe einen v-mann abschalten wollen
der verein gewandt hatte und zwar vor
dem anschlag das bka widerspricht doch
der ermittler bleibt bei seiner version
ich persönlich habe auch keine zweifel
an der glaubhaftigkeit sondern aussagen
nach dem was ich im
untersuchungsausschuss gehört habe
hinzufügen möchte ich noch dass wir
inzwischen auch in feierlich dokumente
einsehen konnten aus nordrhein westfalen
insbesondere die die aussagen stützen
das attentat vom breitscheidplatz wer
wusste wann was wer hat versagt und soll
etwas vertuscht werden viele offene
fragen noch immer drei jahre nach einem
der folgenschwersten terroranschläge in
deutschland jetzt zwei wichtige
kabinettsentscheidungen sogenannte
konversions therapien
also versuche homosexuelle von ihrer
angeblichen krankheit zu heilen sollen
für minderjährige komplett für
volljährige teilweise verboten werden
wer dagegen verstößt muss mit einer
freiheitsstrafe von bis zu einem jahr
oder einem hohen bußgeld rechnen
außerdem hat das kabinett eine strategie
beschlossen mit der es den
energieverbrauch in deutschland
drastisch senken will
bis 2030 sollen 30 prozent im vergleich
zum jahr 2008 eingespart werden dabei
geht es vor allem darum die nutzung von
kohle öl und gas zu verringern
ein ziel das durch den umbau der
energiewirtschaft auf erneuerbare
energien erreicht werden
zur stunde in polen im ganzen land
demonstrieren zehntausende gegen die
justizreformen der
national-konservativen regierungspartei
peace sie sprechen von dem versuch
richter an die leine zu legen sehen die
unabhängigkeit der justiz in gefahr
auch das oberste gericht in polen sagt
die reform verstoße gegen eu-recht
aus warschau berichtet natalie steger es
ist ein breiter protest in gleich
mehreren städten und ein machtkampf mit
polens regierung
denn die nationalkonservativen pis will
richter weitreichend kontrollieren mit
einem neuen gesetzentwurf
wenn ein richter heute nicht mehr sagen
darf was er denkt dann kann mir das
morgen genau so passiert es könnte dazu
kommen dass man das rückgrat der leute
bricht die anderer meinung sind als die
regierung
nach dem gesetzentwurf soll es richtern
verboten werden sich politisch zu äußern
etwa bei solchen demonstrationen
außerdem könnten sie abgesetzt oder
sogar entlassen werden wenn sie
richterkollegen vorwerfen von der
regierung abhängig zu sein
polens staatspräsident der gesetze
letzten endes unterschreiben muss steht
bereits hinter dem entwurf bestimmungen
sind in polen sehr nötig die klar und
deutlich festlegen wir ich dann nicht
handeln sollten wie sie sich nicht
äußern sollten und was sie nicht tun
sollten
der einfluss der politik auf die justiz
ist bereits groß kritiker sehen die
gewaltenteilung nun in noch größerer
gefahr
der gesetzentwurf ist ein maulkorbgesetz
er soll augen münder und hände der
richter schließen und so werden aus den
polnischen richtern einfache beamte der
druck der straße ist ihre einzige macht
denn die pis hat die absolute mehrheit
im parlament
der senat kann gesetze nicht blockieren
die pis will bislang jedenfalls den
gesetzentwurf durchziehen
jetzt seine entscheidung mit folgen für
fischerei und artenschutz in deutschland
im kommenden jahr dürfen fischer
deutlich weniger kabeljau und dafür mehr
makrelen fangen darauf haben sich die eu
fischereiminister geeinigt und die
fangquoten für die nordsee festgelegt
demnach darf nur noch die hälfte der
bisherigen kabeljau menge gefischt
werden
so sollen sich die bestände wieder
erholen
sein einsatz für dialog und versöhnung
brachte ihn hinter gitter
der chinesische regierungskritiker ilham
tohti bekam lebenslang wegen
separatismus das war vor sechs jahren
jetzt wurde er mit dem renommierten
sacharow preis des europaparlaments
ausgezeichnet
doch das volk die uiguren sind eine
ethnische minderheit muslimischen
glaubens im norden chinas mehr als eine
million von ihnen sind
menschenrechtsaktivisten zufolge in
umerziehungslager nein gesperrt gunnar
krüger aus straßburg das foto ihres
vaters hält sie hoch wie zum zeichen der
ihren platz der applaus der preis all
das gebührt ihm
aber ihr habt doch die ökonomen und
aktivist sitzt noch immer im gefängnis
seine tochter pranger tina an für ein
ganzes system aus arbeitslagern peking
behauptet und man bekämpfe dort
extremismus dort zwingen sie die figuren
religion sprache und kultur aufzugeben
es gibt zwangsarbeit und folter manche
starben
das europa parlament stärkt nun die
position der uiguren folgt darauf auch
politik eines der grundprinzipien muss
sein dass aus diesen regionen vor allem
aus diesen lagern sichergestellt werden
muss dass keine produkte nach europa
geliefert werden das nicht für
zwangsarbeit dass die produkte aus
zwangsarbeit nichteuropäischen der
supermarkt tischen landen
zudem arbeitet das parlament mit dem rat
der europäischen union an einem gesetz
das selbst in chinas westen sanktionen
ermöglicht ich glaube das wäre ein
wichtiges ergebnis dass man gegen zum
beispiel den kommunistischen partei
schon von kind ja tatsächlich so
vorgehen kann wie es die usa zb in
vergleichbaren fällen das tun
das ließe sich mit china anlegen den
willen dazu hat zumindest das
europaparlament heute bekundet
und dem sport auch heute zunächst der
blick auf die fußball-bundesliga
christina da bleibt es weiter spannend
die herbstmeisterschaft ist offen das
topspiel zwischen dortmund und leipzig
endete 3 3
nachher kann der rest des spitzen
quintett nachlegen schalke die bayern
und gladbach könnte sogar zum
tabellenführer aus sachsen aufschließen
die wunden nach der last minute
niederlage beim vfl wolfsburg am sonntag
sind auch frisch doch für den
heilungsprozess bleibt bei borussia
mönchengladbach kaum zeit
es kommt der tabellenletzte aus
paderborn und dato trainer marco rose
gut daran den gegner zu loben
die gehen jeden jeden spieltag raus und
geben vollgas suchen ihre chance sind
positiv grundsätzlich lob gibt es auch
von den bayern vor der reise zum
tabellennachbarn aus freiburg das
scheint beim bundesliga trainer in mode
zu sein
wer spielt in freiburg in der mannschaft
die zurecht auch da steht wo sie steht
sie hat man sagen der verein absolut top
muss man regelungen des trainers lob für
den gegner kann offenbar nicht schaden
wenn man als klarer favorit ins rennen
geht
in london gab es eine umjubelte premiere
im das erstmalig hat eine frau bei einer
weltmeisterschaft das duell gegen einen
mann in runde eins gewonnen
kurz nach dem historischen triumph
laufen die tränen fällen sherlock
überwältigt von ihren gefühlen und der
großen unterstützung der zuschauer
im duell mit ihrem englischen landsmann
ted es gibt sie ein ganz anderes bild ab
treffsicher vor nervosität nichts zu
spüren
immer wieder finden ihre darts den weg
in das kleine rote fällt jedes mal 60
punkte wert sie begeistert die grölende
menge und beeindruckt immer mehr ihren
kontrahenten eine frau die in dieser
sportart nicht nur phasenweise mit hält
sondern auch die entscheidenden momente
für sich verbucht ein novum bei der pdc
wm-tickets die nummer 77 der welt
versucht es mit fassung zu tragen er ist
raus fällen cherop darf am samstagabend
gegen den nächsten mann weiter waffen
genau da kommt aus österreich nur zwei
frauen durften mitmachen die andere
schiebt ganz knapp aus der hinweis ist
die drahtzieherin auf einem riesen
interesse gestoßen sind ja die
lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 19
20 25 42 48 und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
auch morgen wieder ein auffällig milder
und sonniger septem dezembertag
september aber es ist dezember
nur mancherorts hält sich der nebel auch
mal länger wo das erfahren sie gleich
von katja hornisse das war es von uns
schön dass sie dabei waren claus kleber
erwartet sie um 21 45 zum heute journal
und an dieser stelle freut sich morgen
barbara hahlweg auf sie
schönen abend noch bis bald
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren auch
heute konnten wieder viele von ihnen die
sonne sehen und die hpa letzten
regenwolken die verließen deutschland
nordostwärts und heute nacht bildet sich
zum teil dicker nebel besonders in der
osthälfte und da kann es zum teil auch
gefährlich glatt werden auf den straßen
denn zumindest in sachsen anhalt und
brandenburg wie auch in bayern
sinken die temperaturen am boden in den
frost ganz anders sieht es am
niederrhein aus da liegen die
tiefsttemperaturen bei sieben grad und
auch morgen wird es in der region am
wärmsten bis zu 16 grad
anders sieht es in vorpommern aus oder
auch auf rügen da liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nur so bei sechs bis
sieben grad und das liegt dann auch
daran dass sich nebel dort verhalten
kann richtung westen dagegen scheint
häufiger die sonne und auch in
süddeutschland gibt es so ein
ost-west-gefälle was den nebel angeht
besonders in der oberpfalz oder auch an
der donau und im allgäu hält sich der
nebel c vielleicht auch am oberrhein
aber generell ist es im westen dort
freundlicher je nachdem ob sich der film
so ein bisschen durchsetzen kann oder ob
es dauer grau bleibt liegen die
temperaturen zwischen 3 grad im dauer
grauen 14 grad mit föhn am alpenrand
danach kommt strom und das vierte
adventswochenende wird regte schönen
abend noch